mot d'abord sur emmanuel macron qui va
prendre la parole demain pour le 14
juillet il n'a pas parlé depuis les
législatives ont dit qu emmanuel macron
il a compris ce qui s'était passé aux
législatives mais qui n'a pas encore
accepté crois pas que ce soit le cas je
crois qu'il a compris et accepté parce
que d'ailleurs pour comprendre il faut
avoir accepté au fond sinon sinon on
comprends pas et je pense qu'il en a
tiré des conclusions et il l'a dit
d'ailleurs dans un certain nombre de ces
expressions même si c'est pas
l'expression du 14 juillet la volonté
qu'il avait d'avancer dans les réformes
l'avancé avec la boule à l'équation que
nous avons à l'assemblée nationale qui
est une équation de majorité relative de
majorité quand même une majorité
relative et donc la nécessité à la fois
de changer sur un certain nombre de
méthodes sans doute mais il avait dit à
vrai dire avant l'épisode législatif
pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse avancer
qu'on puisse à la fois développer le
projet et en même temps l'amendé de ce
qu'il faudra l'amendé vous dites changer
de méthode alors c'est vrai qu'il ya une
petite phrase qui est pas passée
inaperçue
concernant ses liens et son action avec
la société au beurre il a dit ça m'en
touche une sans sans bouger l'autre sur
la méthode justement et sur la forme est
ce que il a raison de parler comme ça
d'abord s'il faisait référence à une
citation d'un ancien président de la
règle mais li l'a jamais dit occupe
certes peut-être mais après tout que
parfois le président de la république
puisse dire les choses de manière assez
cash sa n'insulte personne il dit
simplement
ce qu'ils pensent d'une espèce de monter
en épingle et c'est assez souvent
estivale d'ailleurs c'est intéressant à
regarder montée on n'est pas quelque
chose qui est aussi simple qu'un
ministre de l'économie et des finances à
l'époque qui rencontre une entreprise
pas si à chaque fois qu'un ministre de
l'économie des finances rencontre une
entreprise ça pose un problème sauf à
certains c'est un problème ça pourrait
être valable pour d'autres grandes
entreprises qui font rencontrer ces
importants des rencontres on lui
reproche pas finalement de recevoir des
chefs d entreprise on lui fait un
reproche d'avoir favorisé l'implantation
du bear qui ne paye pas ses impôts en
france et puis en plus petit pré carré
ses salariés enfin surtout le ski en
première intention et d'ailleurs on a
avancé sur les questions salariales et
les questions de conditions de travail
des salariés mais l'important quand même
c'est qu'on ait pu développer quelque
chose qui a permis à des milliers de
jeunes de trouver on le constate tous
les jours de trouver un emploi et à près
de travailler aussi également sur les
questions de sécurisation de l'emploi et
de lutte contre la précarité mais à la
vérité le déploiement d'hubert en france
a plutôt été un élément positif en
particulier en termes d'emploi
un mot encore sur sur ce qui s'est passé
hier soir à l'assemblée nationale
l'article 2 sur le projet de loi
sanitaire a été retoqué l'article au dos
et le l'adoption du pass sanitaires aux
frontières est ce que
ça préfigure de ce que va être cette
mandature j'espère que ça ne préfigure
pas parce que c'est un me semble-t-il un
grand acte d'irresponsabilité
de quoi s'agissait-il il s'agissait il
s'agit d'ailleurs le texte poursuit sa
navette de mettre en place aux
frontières un pass qui permet en cas de
variants hautement pathogène de
contrôler les personnes qui arrivent ou
les personnes qui sortent mais les
personnes qui arrivent principalement
pour faire en sorte d'éviter d'importer
si je peux dire le virus je rappelle
d'ailleurs au passage qu'un certain
nombre de gens qui ont voté contre cet
article là et elles mêmes qui nous
demandait la fermeture des frontières je
pense à madame le pen alors
manifestement et un revirement de
situation il ne fait de coalition alors
c'est intéressant de voir qu'à une
coalition rassemblement national du ps
l air pur en fait se priver d'un outil
qui est un outil de protection des
populations et qui principalement
touchés eux qui sont aux frontières
alors si certains nous propose une autre
alternative pourquoi pas mais je ne la
vois pas l'alternative c'est l'internât
tisser celle que proposait madame le pen
c'est de fermer les frontières croyez
que c'est quelque chose qui est possible
et raisonnable mais ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire que c'était pas assez
verrouillé en tenant le travail de tout
fait avant d'arriver dans le débats de
l'hémicycle comme vous savez je connais
un peu le travail parlementaire parce
qu'effectivement j'ai été ministre des
relations avec le parlement le travail
des commissions avait été fait puisque
le texte qui arrive est il arrivé avec
ce pass aux frontières sauf que les
cette surprise mais très bien oui c'est
plutôt une surprise et c'est plutôt
c'est pas la question de la surprise je
jouerai pas qu'il ya une espèce de
d'émulation a simplement se dire on l'a
battu le gouvernement ça n'a aucun
intérêt de savoir si on bat le
gouvernement à la question de savoir est
ce qu'on dispose d'outils qui permettent
de protéger les français sur ces textes
là est ce qu'on aura demain un texte sur
le pouvoir d'achat qui permettra de
répondre aux questions de pouvoir
d'achat des français hors jeu j'ai senti
hier soir une forme de sentiment d'
irresponsabilité collective qui s'est
emparée d'un certain nombre
d'oppositions et je le regrette parce
que je pense que sur un certain nombre
de textes on peut essayer de trouver des
terrains d'entente mais un pass aux
frontières c'est un pass qui permet je
le répète de protéger les populations en
cas de virus et donc se priver de cet
outil là c'est regrettable il ya une
lavette il va aller au sénat il valait à
l'assemblée nationale il reviendra à
l'assemblée nationale puis au sénat
j'espère que la raison l'emportera et
que au delà de la contingence de delà de
la soirée si je peux dire les
oppositions maintenant sont en situation
de responsabilité parce que quand la
majorité relative les oppositions elles
ont un rôle et une responsabilité donc
c'est pas lorraine de les
responsabilités qui doit se développer
donc on verra ça au prix internet vous
êtes ministre de l'agriculture vous est
aussi ministre de la sécurité
alimentaire souveraineté nager par ntv
la souveraineté alimentaire m'enfin y'a
aussi quelque part j'avais tout à fait
un souhait de sécurité manger trop de
charcuterie peut causer des cancers
c'est ce qu'a dit l' agence de sécurité
sanitaire de l'alimentation en cause
c'est l'ajout de nitrites et nitrates
dans ces produits vous v annoncé hier un
plan visant à les réduire réduire ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que de toute
façon peut pas s'en passer enfin pour un
certain nombre de raisons que dit
d'ailleurs lançait ce pour des raisons
sanitaires elle aussi mais d'autres
raisons sanitaires notamment la lutte
contre les salmonelles et autres
développements bactériologique à
l'intérieur de ces 2 s'est produit il ya
besoin de ces ccsn nitrites et
simplement on avait dit quelque chose au
mois de janvier enfin à la fin de
l'automne qu'il y aurait un rapport de
nantes 16 pour savoir le degré et la
dangerosité éventuelle des nitrites le
lançait sa répondu qu'il y avait un
facteur qui pouvaient être liés sans
doute aux cancers colorectaux et donc on
va seront va se conformer aux
préconisations lancé moi j'aime assez
quand on se conforme à ce que dit la
science on interroge la science elle
nous donne des éléments on va se
conformer elle nous invite à réduire
donc en présence bas on verra avec eux
et essayer préciser les données un de
réduire les rides de de réduire et de
limiter la consommation de charcuteries
dans un cadre qui raisonnable que chacun
peut comprendre ce qui est souvent
toxiques c'est le trop de quelque chose
ce n'est pas le produit lui-même c'est
l'excès du produit lui-même c'est ce sur
quoi il faut qu'on travaille et puis
avec les filières on va travailler sur
la réduction d'une stricte il évoque
aussi les nitrates parce qu'un certain
nombre de nitrates et elle par les
végétaux page une compris de manière
naturelle donc il faut qu'on travaille
avec l'ensemble des filières pour se
donner une perspective de réduction face
à la flambée des prix alimentaires
avaient appelé les distributeurs à
prendre leur part vous dites ya encore
des marges d'action alors c'est ma
réaction notamment elle concerne les
promotions sauf que ces promotions avec
la loi
alimentation elle est plafonnée à 34%
alors c'est très simple elle est
plafonnée à 30 4% aujourd'hui les
promotions n'atteignent pas les 34% donc
avant de nous demander au lieu de nous
demander 50 % on est en moyenne autour
de 20 à 25% de promotion dont il ya des
marges dans la grande distribution donc
c'est ça ça serait de passer devant non
mais c'est leur liberté mais avant de
demander des mesures complémentaires ils
vont me regarder les mesures qui peuvent
remettre misa le deuxième élément il
faut rémunérer la matière la matière
agricole ou prix qu'elle est il faut
sortir de cette spirale déflationniste
vous avez un certain de produits qui
aujourd'hui ont exactement le même prix
qu'il ya vingt ans ça veut dire qu'on a
été dans la déflation et donc je serai
le ministre à tous les collègues du
gouvernement qui luttent contre cette
déflation des produits agricoles parce
qu'à la fin c'est la souveraineté parce
que si vous ne réussirez pas les
agriculteurs ça veut dire qu'ils
arrêteront de produire tel ou tel
produit et donc la souveraineté
disparaîtrait ça c'est un élément qui
n'est tine acceptable dans chacun doit
faire sa part le gouvernement vole fait
au travers du chèque alimentation est
ouvert le flanc le fait sur des tas
d'autres mesures le chèque alimentaire
celui qui a été
annoncé en 2020 c'est un peu
l'arlésienne on en est au concret même
si des dispositifs là vous allez en
premier dit spécial travailler avec mon
collègue jean-christophe combes qui
travaille sur les questions de
solidarité lui dise solidarité pour
regarder maintenant le dispositif est ce
assez pour l'automne que les choses
seront prêtes ok merci merci marc
fesneau bonne journée à vous